this mac and cheese is just not only
vegan it is delicious now this is what
mac and cheese is supposed to look like
all right hey guys i'm chef joya and i
am an expert at transitioning non-vegans
to vegan food today on the menu the
cheesiest vegan mac and cheese you've
ever tasted it
alright so we're going to start with a
pot of rapid boiling water and you want
to make sure you always flavor your
water i like to use vegetable bouillon
cubes or if you have powdered vegetable
bouillon you can use that if you have
vegan chicken bouillon you can use that
but whatever you do you want to make
sure you season the water because your
noodles are going to absorb the flavor
and if you don't have any vegetable
bouillon cubes you can use salt but
don't just use plain water whatever you
do
all right so we're going to go ahead and
add our pasta to it we're going to use
elbow noodles so you want to make sure
you use regular apple noodles i know a
lot of times you see the jumbo elbow
noodles no don't use that you're going
to add your top back to the pasta we're
going to cook it about 8 to 10 minutes
so about al dente and stir in between
go drain it you follow it you come with
me or no no i'm by myself okay so we're
gonna add our butter now you can use as
much butter as you want there are no
rules on butter the more butter the
better okay so we're gonna dump that all
into the pan and then we're going to
allow that to melt down once our butter
is melted we're going to add our
all-purpose flour and you want to make
sure that your heat is on medium-low
because you don't want this to burn at
all next we're going to add our tapioca
starch you may also see that the tapioca
starch say tapioca flour those are the
exact same things so you can use that as
well
we're going to go ahead and whisk this
now you're going to need a lot of strong
arm motion because this is a lot of
stirring okay so we're going to mix this
until it's well incorporated and that's
why it's good to leave that residue in
it because it's getting some of that
flavor as well
now this is another one you can use as
much as you want there is no rules on it
just whatever your hearts desire just go
into
it tells you to stop all right
i'm going to blend it all the way down
so once your cream cheese is melted down
you're going to go ahead and add your
slices of cheese this time i'm going to
add about
six slices of my vegan cheese and if you
feel like using more cheese use more
cheese
and this is where our vegan cheddar is
going to come in
add that here
now we're going to go ahead and add our
unsweetened cashew milk now you want to
make sure that you use unsweetened milk
that is the worst
to have a mac and cheese that's super
sweet i don't think anyone will like
that and we're going to add our milk in
a little bit at a time and you want to
also make sure that the milk is already
at room temperature
you don't want to put super cold milk
into your pan because it actually will
seize the cheese so we're going to give
this a nice little stir and like i said
you got to get your manpower up because
we're going to do a lot of stirring so
once that's absorbed like this we're
going to add a little bit more milk
and trust me it is a lot of standing
over the pot but it is worth every
moment at this point our cheese is still
melting down but it's at the point to
where we need to add our seasonings so
we're going to start adding some flavor
we're going to go ahead and add some
black pepper we're going to add a little
bit of sea salt
a little bit of garlic powder
and yes you have to have garlic powder
now don't go adding fresh onions to this
it is not it's it's not what you need
it's not what you need at all
let me get we didn't open all these
so we're going to add our onion powder
and enough until you're about covering
the pan and you're going to see that
your cheese sauce is starting to boil
even more and it should be thick almost
like pancake mix you see that
you want to make sure that all those
flavors are getting incorporated into
the cheese sauce
and remember you can always add but you
can't take away so that's why we add a
little bit of milk at a time next we're
going to add our nutritional yeast and
this is used to give pretty much all the
vegan food their cheesy flavor if you
use way too much of it it tastes really
chalky and i know a lot of vegan mac and
cheeses are very chalky they're not good
so you want to make sure that you don't
use too much of that nutritional yeast
next we're going to use a little bit of
hot sauce now trust me this is not going
to make your mac and cheese spicy at all
but it is going to amplify the flavor
trust me i know if you can't find vegan
worcestershire sauce you can use tamari
you can use coconut aminos you can also
use soy sauce but you want to make sure
you use a very little bit of it just a
little bit
get a nice little stir let's add some
more milk in between there
remember when i say don't use any
sweetened plant-based milk that's
because you're going to add a little bit
of sugar into it you can use any raw
sugar that you like but you're going to
use a very little bit not a lot just a
little bit okay
so we're going to give this a nice stir
and it's almost there look at that pool
we are getting there look at this now
this is what mac and cheese is supposed
to look like all right so the last spice
that we're going to add to this is a
little bit of creole seasoning now i'm
making it more traditional soul food
baked mac and cheese
it is going to be super creamy and
cheesy but we're going to actually put
this in the oven this cheese sauce is
going to attach to the noodles it's
going to thicken up so it's almost like
a pie it's like a thick cheesy gooey
crusty thingamajiggy that you're just
going to love all
right there you go
all the clumps are almost out
like if your mac and cheese don't look
like this i don't want it
i don't for real all right we're going
to add our bouillon to our cheese sauce
and we're going to make sure we mix that
really well let's spread the love
in there
i'm excited i am so excited you see how
good this looks no this this is for real
like this is really like oh yes
we're gonna take our pasta noodles and
we're going to season it with a little
bit more of creole seasoning i like to
use creole seasoning when i first
learned how to make vegan mac and cheese
i would use like salt pepper garlic
powder onion powder paprika but the
thing about it is creole seasoning has
all those flavors all those spices in
there and more creole seasoning is a
one-stop seasoning shop and it has
everything in it that you need all right
so we're gonna go ahead and take our
seasoned pasta noodles and we're gonna
add this to our mac and cheese sauce
like you need your noodles to be
drowning it needs to drown in all of
this cheese sauce if your noodles aren't
drowning you need to make more sauce you
don't want to save these noodles they
need to drown so let's drown the noodles
add them to the pot
and we're going to mix that in there
you may have to poke a little bit of
holes in it push it down to the bottom
so you want to make sure that you taste
your mac and cheese because once you put
it in the oven you can't add any more
seasoning to it so you want to go ahead
and grab it oh make sure oh look at that
i'm like in
mac and cheese heaven right now
now we're going to take our baking dish
and we're going to make sure that we
grease it with a nonstick spray because
this is going to be ooey and gooey and
it will stick and burn and we don't want
that to happen so we're going to go
ahead and add that just pour it right
into the pot oh look at that
look at that magic
we're not done yet because we're going
to add more cheese the way we're going
to do is we're going to like fold it up
like this and we're going to tuck it in
there right so it's kind of like hiding
in there and i actually got this my
cousin when she used to make the
original style of mac cheese she used to
stuff cubes of cheese at the top of her
mac and cheese so i just do it with my
vegan mac that's what you want you don't
even want to be able to move you want to
just be like this like real stuff next
we're going to layer it with more
shredded cheddar cheese you want this
fully covered with our shredded cheese
oh my gosh
look at that
all the bubbles and cracks all that
spillage you want all that spillage
that's when you know it is really done
this isn't good vegan food this is good
food whoa
like
oh goodness
that is so beautiful
cheese pool
[Music]
it's like an entire party in my mouth
this is super creamy
super delicious doesn't taste what you
think is vegan this is just the best
cheesiest mac and cheese ever
like this is good i know you can't say
that but
now that you have the secrets to the
cheesiest vegan mac and cheese let me
know if there's anything else that you
would like for me to veganize comment
below for more delicious recipes you can
follow me at cookingwithjoya on all
social media you can also find more
vegan soul food recipes in my soul food
cookbook called it's so amazing at
cookingwithjoya.com see you guys soon
oh yes
[Music]
you